Game of Thrones star Jason Momoa is  behind the camera in a new explosive  commercial for Carhartt Momoa says  directing is really his dream yep even  though he's playing a superhero Aquaman  in Justice League quote I'm really  excited to get in there I've been  waiting for four years that I've known  about it that I've had to keep my mouth  shut I'm super pumped to shoot it et  chatter with Jason about his production  company pride of Gypsys third  collaboration with the brand quote I  went to them first and told them why I  love them and started our relationship  and now I've been doing their  commercials for the last three years so  you can end the day as strong she  started